[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So we switch gears now and talk
about quantum electrodynamics,
QED.
And we start the
discussion by going back
to free wave equations.
Now could argue that we are
interested in collisions
and we're interested
in decays of particles.
So why do we discuss
free wave equations?
But the theory we
discussed last week,
which we used in order to get
a hold on Feynman diagrams
and calculations,
was very simplified.
And one of the aspects not
considered in this theory
was the fact that
particles carry spin.
So we had a theory which not
only was applicable to scalars.
Now by walking through
wave equations,
we can see how we can
incorporate or make
use of the fact that particles
actually do carry spin.
So let's do this one by one.
So we start off with our
relativistic energy-momentum
relation--
e squared is equal to p
squared plus m squared.
We express energy
and momentum via
quantum mechanical operators.
And so immediately
by putting this in,
we find this
equation here, which
is the so-called
Klein-Gordon wave equation.
So if you look at
this equation, we
see that the second
derivative here in time,
there's no derivative in space.
So there's an asymmetry
between space and time.
And that is a not really useful
feature of our wave equation
as we want them to be, Lorentz
invariant, for example.
So what we want is a first-order
equation in both derivatives.
So we'll just start writing
this down in general terms,
and then make sure that
this equation holds
to the relativistic
information we just
saw on the previous slide.
We'll just write this down here.
We have a first derivative time
and a first derivative space.
And we'll just say there's a
constant between those two,
relating those two.
So the sigmas are just
unknown constants.
So if you now try to find
by squaring this, trying
to find the
Klein-Gordon equation
and relates the
coefficients, you
find this relationship here.
So the sigma squared are
all the same and equal to 1.
But you also see
that the sigmas,
they're anti-commutate-- sorry--
which is not
possible for numbers.
So sigmas need to be matrices.
You also see that this
is only holding true here
for m equal to 0.
So this equation here is
true for a massless particle.
All right, so if we then
try to find solutions
for those relations, we find
that they can be fulfilled
by the 2 by 2 Pauli matrices.
We might have seen
this already hopefully
in the discussion
of atomic physics.
And there, those Pauli matrices
associate spin to electrons.
So this is exactly what
we have in mind here also.
Now using this definition, we
can rewrite the Weyl equations
to energy times the
field is equal to minus
sigma times the momentum
times the field.
And to find a second equation,
we'll just design flips.
The chi here and
the phi spinors,
they're two-dimensional
vectors and the sigma
are our Pauli matrices.
Good.
So we have the relation
of [INAUDIBLE]..
So we can go a step further.
Now we want to introduce
mass term as well.
Those hold for
massless particles,
so we're going introduce mass.
So we can rewrite this equation
and introduce its mass term
here, again, with
the coefficient.
And we find now this
alpha here being--
sorry.
So this phi here is a
core component spinor.
And it stands for the particle,
its antiparticle, and the two
spin states.
So that's combining that
two equations we had here.
So you'll see one
is for particles
and one is for antiparticles,
for the two spin states.
So we combine this
in one equation
and we added this mass term.
So if you try to find
the solutions here,
you find that
alpha is a matrix--
4 by 4 matrix which has the
sigma, supporting matrices
on the off-diagonal elements.
And beta is a
diagonal matrix-- a 4
by 4 matrix with identity
on the upper two components,
and minus 1 in the
lower two components.
So now with this, this is
already the Dirac equation.
We can rewrite the Dirac
equation in the covariant form
where you have just
defined a new matrix here,
so-called gamma matrix
which you build out
of this matrix beta and alpha.
Which are defined on
the previous slide.
Good, so good.
So we have this new
matrix, this new equation
here, which is the
Dirac equation.
And it holds for particles
with two spin states, examples
with spin half states.
And it holds for particles
which have masses.
So that's great.
So this is now on starting
point for the discussion.
The next lecture we'll look
at solutions of this equation.